is the biggest transformation in child
care in my lifetime Jane it's a huge
change and we're going to need thousands
more nurseries thousands more schools
offering provision they don't currently
offer thousands more child minders we
are going as fast as we can get the
supply in the market to expand but it's
the right thing to do because we have
one of the most expensive Child Care
Systems in the world and we know that
it's something that's a huge worry for
women in particular that they have this
Cliff Edge when maternity leave ends
after nine months no help until the
child turns three and that can often be
career ending so I think it's the right
thing to do for many many women to
introduce these reforms and we are
introducing them as quickly as we can